it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all strive for it and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists like Richard Feynman
Nobel Prize winner he's most famous for
Bongo drumming naked on the roof of
Caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
I if I Come Away with nothing else I
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got